hello everyone in this video we'll talk
about gastrine
gastrin is a local hormone found in the
gastrointestinal system
whose major function is to secrete the
gastric
hcl so in this video we would look at
what is gastrin
what is the function of gastrin what is
the mechanism of action and finally what
are the factors that regulate gastrin
secretion
if you haven't yet subscribed to my
channel hit that subscribe button and
please watch the video till the end
so gastrine is a peptide hormone and its
major function
is gastric hcl secretion from the
parietal cell
now gastrin also aids in gastric
motility and
contraction of the stomach and thereby
it helps
mobilizing the food particles or the
partially digested food particles
from the stomach to the intestine now
gastrin is a linear peptide hormone
produced by g cells of the duodenum
and in the pyloric antrum of the stomach
now gastrin can exist in three different
forms
one is big gastrin which is 34 amino
acid long
gastrin 17 or little gastrin which is 17
amino acid long
and a mini gastrin which is 14 amino
acid long now gastrin
as expected it's a peptide hormone so it
would be encoded by
a gene and this gene is known as gas
gene which is located in the 17th
chromosome in human
inside the 17 chromosome there would be
gas gene which ultimately transcribes
and translates into a precursor form of
gastrin which is known as progastrin
from the pro-gas stream there would be
translational modification which
leads to production of big gastrin mini
gastrin or little gastrin
now gastrin is released in response of
certain stimuli and we would learn about
them
so the first stimuli that helps in
gastrin secretion is
partially digested proteins amino acids
etc
especially the aromatic amino acids such
as tyrosine phenylalanine
or tryptophan etc now secondly
hypercalcemia can increase
gastrin secretion stomach detention
and vagal nerve stimulation has also
positive
effect in terms of gastrin secretion let
us look at the factors that
inhibits secretion first of all
the presence of too much hcl gives a
feedback
and prevents gastrin secretion because
and thereby
reducing the gastrin secretion reduces
the hcl
secretion as well from the parietal cell
lastly there are many
hormones such as gip secretin
vip glucagon etc which
prevents gastrin secretion and thereby
prevent the gastric hcl secretion as
well
so now let us look at a particular
parietal cell
and let's see what gastrin does so
gastrin
stimulates the parietal cell of the
stomach to stimulate
to to secrete the hydrochloric acid now
it can also indirectly work on the
enterochromatin cells and there would be
cck2 or gastrin receptors
which can bind to gastrin 17 or mini
gastrin
ultimately this leads to secretion of
histamine
histamine receptors are also present in
this parietal cell
histamine indirectly stimulate parietal
cell
to secrete further hcl so what we
learned
that gastrin can directly stimulate
parietal cell or it can
aid in the production of histamine which
indirectly stimulate gastric hcl so the
endo
end result is to secrete gastric hcl
so other functions of gastrin
includes it secretes
it it helps the chief cell to secrete
pepsinogen
and thereby aid in protein digestion it
increases
enteral muscle mobility and promotes
stomach contraction
also it strengthens the anterior
contraction
against the pirola pylorus and relaxes
the pyloric sphincter which increases
the rate of gastric emptying so
at what rate the stomach would be
emptied is kind of modulated by gastrin
levels
ultimately it also induces pancreatic
secretion
and help in gallbladder emptying so
these are few important
roles of gastrin in the gastrointestinal
system
so lastly let's summarize what we have
learned
so we learned how gastrin is secreted
then we
talked about factors that affects
gastrin secretion
and we also reviewed the functions of
gastrin other than
gastric hcl secretion so i hope you
enjoyed this video if you
like this video give it a quick thumbs
up don't forget to like share and
subscribe and do let me know in the
comment how you like my video
your comment give me so much positive
modification motivation that i can make
more videos like these
my courses are also available in an
academy if you want to
access those course you can use my code
ap 10 to get a 10
discount and thanks for listening thank
you see you in the next video